more Ugandan soldiers arriving in
Democratic Republic of Congo they're
under the banner of an East African
Regional Force it's meant to end the
conflict between government forces and
the M23 armed group ugandans have
crossed into the Border Town of bunagana
it was taken by M23 last year and its
Fighters are still there this requires a
lot of strategic patience
and we have to agree all of us that we
have to be patient we have been waiting
for long and waiting for a few days or a
few months I don't think is going to do
any harm
n23 has taken swathes of territory from
Congolese government forces over the
last year
it's widely understood to be a proxy of
neighboring Rwanda
Uganda has also been accused of backing
the group those governments deny it
Uganda is the third country to join the
regional Force Kenya and Burundi have
already sent troops Congo's Army said
the regional forces would help it fight
M23 instead they've been making
agreements with the armed group
M23 hasn't obeyed Regional leaders calls
for it to withdraw and disarm
every time when we draw from a place the
government forces and local armed groups
are still coming back this time we have
agreed with the East African forces that
such kind of behavior will be considered
as violation of ceasefire and we will
react immediately
people have protested against Rwanda and
Uganda in cities across Congo in recent
years they're blamed for decades of
military aggression and looting of
minerals ever since they first invaded
in the 1990s
two years ago thousands of Ugandan
soldiers entered Congolese territory
near the town of Benny under an
agreement with Congo's government
they're meant to be pursuing an armed
group called The ADF rights groups take
violence against civilians has grown
worse since they arrived
now people are wondering if the arrival
of even more foreign forces will help to
end Decades of conflict Malcolm Webb Al
Jazeera